Andrew hubman mentioned in an interview
that I did with him recently that the
potential mental health epidemic that
we're seeing at the moment could be
Downstream of poor Cadian Rhythm uh
disregulated sleep disrupted sleep how
much truth do you think's in that o
circadian medicine is really top tier
science right now we're synced up with
the 24-hour solar day all of our hormone
production our neurotransmitters we're
synced up with what the universe is
doing and the funny thing is hum can
kind of hide out from that that
interface but our our genes are really
expecting us to be in constant
communication with what's happening
outside and humans are really
interesting we can create our own
habitats we're kind of like big hairless
beavers or many of us are hairless um
but even when we're creating it's still
nature because we're a part of nature
but we can essentially hide out and
create a 24-hour day artificially and so
our circadian Timing System is getting
really screwed up so absolutely I agree
with him and here's the rub right now in
the United States estimated about 115
million Americans are regularly sleep
deprived to boot out of 330 yeah so it's
a sizable amount and we're talking about
on a regular basis like essentially
daily and my big thing is always looking
for what is the connective tissue why
should people really care about this and
I I always like to tie to metabolic
health and how we look right and a
really fascinating study was done this
was actually published by the American
Academy of sleep medicine and they
looked at
people's Biometrics and use CT scans to
look at their belly fat for 5 years
tracking a group of people and they
found that people who were sleep
deprived gained over twice as much belly
fat in that 5-year period and sleep
deprived in this particular study was
less than 6 hours a night all right so
kind of there's something about six as
being that sweet spot and by the way
there is no cookie cutter amount of
sleep that's one of those things that
you know we just kind of drink eight
glasses of 8 oz water a day like it's
very superficial is that the same for
Shaq and for Simone bils it's going to
be different and the same thing holds
true with sleep it's not just the number
of hours is the quality of those hours
it's a lot like the calorie conversation
you know yes calories matter but the
quality of those calories definitely
matter and I've been a big proponent in
pushing into popular culture this term
epic caloric controller recently which
we can Circle back to and talk about but
in particular with sleep I want to share
one other piece too because especially
right now in this energy equation and
how important this is and some of your
friends and colleagues as well like doc
Dr Gabrielle Li really good friend of
mine we're looking at how important
testosterone is not just for maintaining
our muscle mass and our energy but for
longevity and this is critical for men
and women it's finally really shifting
gears to be all-encompassing of humanity
how how important testosterone is now
listen to this this was published in
2011 in jamama the journal the American
Medical Association top tier medical
journal here in the United States and
they tracked young men average age about
24 all right and they brought them into
the lab and they put them in as award
study so they sleep deprived them for
just one week all right so they
basically got 5 hours of sleep for one
week that one we period their
testosterone dropped 15% % all right now
that might not sound like a lot but
suddenly that's as if they're 10 to 15
years older as far as their testosterone
production is concerned this is the
power of sleep testosterone is right
next to HGH are most sleep duration
dependent hormones it's kind of like
you're a human Tesla jacking into your
charging station at night and filling up
the testosterone there are things we can
get little spikes during the day but
basically when we get up testosterone's
just going down and when we go to sleep
it starts Rising again so if you are not
performing in the bedroom or in the gym
in the way that you want it might be
because of how much sleep you're getting
on a nighttime absolutely and it's
always the first thing to go
unfortunately you know and it's just
part of our culture but fortunately
things are are changing you know this
has become a big part of our popular
conversation especially in health
circles and it tends to trickle its way
out to the larger culture scape
eventually but you know my first book
came out in 2015 I believe and it was
the first sleep Wellness related book to
become an international bestseller it
had never been done before it's just
like the public wasn't necessarily
interested in that topic but I argue
against that it wasn't that we're not
interested in it we didn't know how much
it mattered and it wasn't framed in a
way that made sense and that's kind of
my story going to a conventional
University and having biology and having
Kinesiology and nutritional science but
really not understanding how that is
applicable to me as a human being yeah
right so when we're in biology and we're
looking at the human cell my professor
did not know nor had they made that
Revelation nor did any other the
students that as we're looking at the
mitochondria that mitochondria is made
from our meals as we're looking at the
cell nucleus that's made from the
nutrients that we eat as we're looking
at the cell membrane it's made from our
menu all of the things we're looking at
is made from food and that interace
between our diet our sleep our movement
all of these things are impacting the
cells that we're actually building right
down to the the level of the genes and
for probably about 10 years now I've
been really keeping my finger on the
pulse of something called neutr gentics
and neutr genomics so these are fields
of science looking at how our nutrition
is impacting our genetic expression and
one of my
mentors incredible incredible thinker uh
Pioneer in epigenetics Dr Bruce Lipton
he's a cell
biologist and he really impressed that
the term epigenetics into popular
culture he's the guy and one of our
early conversations he was sharing with
me that you know when they did the Human
Genome Project we just knew there was
going to be like a million different
genes for humans right because there
there's bananas that have more genes
than us there's corn that has more jees
than us they found about 25,000
jeans and the question was how are we so
diverse how do we look so different how
our personality so different our
different levels of health and
functionality all these different things
what's so remarkable about us that he
highlighted for me is that with one
epigenetic influence like a bite of food
it can change a Gene's because in in
school we were taught DNA to RNA to
protein So eventually we're printing out
proteins one bite of food can
change what proteins are getting printed
out out to the variety of about 3,000
different options of what type of
proteins are getting printed so
basically copies of you that are getting
printed out there 3,000 options with one
gene so that's the power of food it's
the power of sleep these are the top
tier things to pay attention to but we
tend to run out let me get that new
supplement let me get that you know
whatever we're looking for all these
external you know inputs but truly for
my money I'm putting it on optimizing
your sleep first and foremost and then
let's work on the other stuff so you can
be a badass while you're awake yeah the
performance enhancer that you're looking
for is not in a supplement store but
it's at your bedtime and your wake time
what are what is it that's causing this
Mass disregulation like I can throw Bro
Science out there and guess what I think
is going on but is there any
longitudinal research looking at the
average amount of time that people used
to spend asleep do now quality of sleep
micro Awakenings REM deep Etc what are
we looking at kind of across time with
regards to sleep over the last 50 years
oh such a good question so as you know
things have changed dramatically in the
last about 50 years and one thing to to
kind of transition into that and part of
the reason that my first book sleeps
Marty was so successful is that I
understood the missing link between all
this incredible insight and all the
science we've gained the past 50 years
and making it applicable for people
which is we need to make this simple
because it is and so coming from a
conventional education I started off my
career I've been in the field for 21
years now speaking in the language of
Academia and a a little not so fun fact
is that it takes upwards of about 15
years for us to have like a gold
standard randomized Placebo control
double blind study all the things it
might affirm you know what we're talking
about today with improving your sleep
quality before it gets like put into
conventional education all right it's a
huge lag this is in the age of the
internet all right it doesn't make any
sense and so what I did was because of
working with people which is very
different than just again working from
Theory which that can be true but it's
different when you sit face to face with
somebody and they're depending on you to
help them to get where they want to be
and I knew this really interesting
secret about humans which is we want
change we want change we want the
results but we don't want to change much
to get
it and okay I'm going say that again we
want change but we don't want to change
that much we might not be happy with
where we are who we are but we're
comfortable with that and so changing
too much at once creates so much
turbulence and so we really what we
would ideally want is take who we are
now and give us the new body take this
person give me the money right I don't
have to qualify myself to have it and so
knowing that this is the case
I started looking for what are the
lowest hanging fruits right what are the
things people can do to optimize their
Sleep Quality without having to turn
their life upside down and so I was
looking
for things that were science-backed but
very
simple now saying all this to transition
this this into this question in the last
50 years we've seen the onset of hustle
culture right there's always throughout
Humanity there's always been a certain
Guild of people who are B quote burning
the midnight oil and looking out and you
know standing guard for our tribe and
whatnot but that's a small sect of
humans for the most part nighttime
danger we don't see like other animals
do like that lion can see you at night
you can't necessarily see it we're not
really hardwired for nocturnal activity
with that being the
case optimizing what we're doing during
the day is going to help us to actually
sleep better at night and that's really
the key so one of my tenants is that a
good night of sleep starts the moment
that that you wake up in the morning and
understanding we've kind of devolved
from our state of seeking shelter
seeking Comfort at night in a safe place
and waiting for the sun to rise
basically so that things are safer now
we've created this situation where we
can basically like I mentioned earlier
create a 24-hour artificial day and we
can just be up whenever so this is a new
opportunity for us as as people yes
there were people back in the day they
got they had a lot of candles you know
but it's still very different we evolved
even with fire for quite some time and
that candle light here's a really
interesting study and this also points
to like one of the things that we can do
to improve our Sleep Quality some
researchers at Cornell took a test
subject and put them in a completely
dark room all right they wanted to track
their actual Sleep Quality so they were
looking at their their brain waves they
were looking at what their brain was
doing and they put a light the size of a
quarter behind their knee and that was
wasn't enough to throw them out of their
sleep cycles so it was disrupting their
Sleep Quality just by that light
exposure behind their knee it's do
something special photo receptor
modulation behind the knee or is this
the same as if you did it on the palm of
my hand or the back of my shoulder it
could be pretty much anywhere because
our skin from head to toe has photo
receptors that pick up light and send
signals to every other cell in our
bodies but because this particular
subject was so deprived of any light the
very small amount of light was we have
no signal oh we do have a signal and
it's behind the knee yeah and we will
follow that based on and we will then
run the Cadian clock off that because
our all of our other cells are trying to
figure out what time is it yep right
there's this light coming in me
knows ni yeah yeah all right I knew a
girl named ni so here's the thing when
we understand this really remarkable
influence if you talk even with you know
Andrew huberman in our convers ation
really talking about this Advent this
new term called light pollution and how
light is top tier as far as really
syncing up our our cells our biology
with all of life right I mentioned that
we're kind of lined up with a 24-hour
solar day and so it's light is really
the kind of tip of the spear and so
using that to our advantage recently
because we simply didn't know we just
started consuming you know like there's
a lot we're in the Golden Age of
Television there's a lot of great stuff
to watch we got our
devices and you know we got fomo there's
also there's so much going on we don't
want to miss out and so we're constantly
having this influx of light information
and it's completely throwing our clocks
off I know it when I'm in the studio for
example all day under artificial lights
I can have I see a
noticeable detriment to my Sleep Quality
that night it just it is what it is and
I do but now of course I know little
things that I can kind of help to
optimize this and so pointing to a tip
like what is one what are one of the
things that we could do knowing that our
SK and by the way let me give a very
logical example when the sun is hitting
your skin it can literally change the
color of your skin all right you have
photo receptors that are picking up
light all the time all right and the Sun
is very different though the the Lux the
the the power of that light is
so otherworldly it is such a special
thing man like it's like that's how we
have life here and now we of course in
our culture we've been sort of
programmed more so to fear the sun right
and so we need to have more balanced
perspective but at the same time of
course respect it it's very powerful
with that being said it's not Moonlight
that disrupts in the same way that
artificial lights do which the moon can
seem kind of bright like it's a bright
but it's the Lux of that light the way
that it's the way that that light is
emanating we evolved with that as well
it's like cellular data that makes sense
like it's nighttime Andrew said that
fight doesn't disrupt Cadian Rhythm
there it is very simple and so if we
look at what we have had thousands upon
thousands of years next to as far as a
light that we create well not that we
created but we can generate with fire
that is a different Hue right it's kind
of this orangish reddish like it's a
it's a softer tone of light and so if we
do want to have some form of light in a
room maybe like a a good salt lamp or
something on a low dimmer for NightLight
versus the bright ass like NightLight
that my grandmother gave me you know so
here's my point one of the best ways and
the first way that I noticeably
improveed My Sleep Quality and it was
one of those launching pads to writing
the book in the first place is when I
got some blackout curtains for my room
all right total darkness never really
slept in total darkness before except
when I was at like if I go to travel to
speak at an event and they had like a
really nice hotel room and the blackout
curtains just like man this this and I
would attribute it to the place like
this place is great but it's the Sleep
Quality that happened in that
environment and so I got some blackout
curtains and that night man my sleep was
phenomenal and so if you are okay with
the dark which most of us are but of
course some people have you know some
neuro associations to where they want to
have you know maybe a little bit of
light that is one of the fastest ways to
improve your Sleep Quality because
melatonin requires basically two
prerequisites one is darkness and the
other is kind of a cyclical nature right
being able to be produced at the same
time
essentially closely day today this is
why we have this new term of social jet
lag as well where you know again we kind
of stick to a routine but on the weekend
everything is like whatever and then we
have that lag on Monday you know you got
a case of the Mondays it's not the fact
that we're going back to work it's that
man my my whole [__] is thrown off and
I'm sleep deprived now we'll get back to
talking to Sean in one minute but first
I need to tell you about element element
is a science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium you need
to stop having coffee first thing in the
morning because your adenosine system
that caffeine acts on isn't even active
for the first 90 minutes of the day but
your adrenal system is and salt act on
your adrenal system I used element for
years before I started working with them
because it tastes fantastic and it helps
to optimize brain health it regulates
your appetite and it curbs Cravings just
because you're drinking water does not
mean that you're properly hydrated you
also need the electrolytes to carry that
in your body best of all they have a no
BS no questions asked refund policy
where you can buy 100% risk-free And if
you do not love it for any reason they
will give you your money back and you
don't even need to return the box that's
how confident they are that you love it
head to the link in the description
below or go to drink LM nt.com wisdom to
get a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box that's drink
LM nt.com
slod wisdom Beyond light pollution which
I think everybody can kind of see 50
years uh you know go back 100 years I
don't even think that you would have had
uh lights within the home be widely
available Advent of radio which is
stimul but no no light TV devices blue
screens tons and tons of screen time
what else have been the biggest changes
I mean you mentioned even sort of
cultural impacts like sort of the desire
to hustle and grind um what else do you
think have been the biggest movers and
changes aside from light pollution over
the last 50 years such a great question
you said the key word you said the CW
culture culture exactly let's Define
culture culture is defined as the shared
attitudes values beliefs and behaviors
of a group of people pass from one
generation to the next all right culture
is functioning as an invisible hand
that's guiding our
decisions here in the United States we
have aspirations of Freedom we believe
that we are totally free but our freedom
is based on the choices that we've been
exposed to in our culture there are
certain choices that we don't even know
exist y you're free within the
constraints of what you're aware of
exactly because even our Cravings are
cultural the food that We crave is
cultural it's based on the things that
we've been exposed to there are people
in other cultures who crave different
things because that is what has been
impressed upon them is human food like
there are folks in Cambodia that will
gladly eat a deep fried tarantula and
it's real talk you know it's a real
thing delicacy have you had it before no
have you no I haven't no but apparently
tastes good all right there are folks in
Iceland eating fermented shark you know
there's folks in Kenya eating yamacha
barbecue goat meat all right the list
goes on and on some of these things
might seem very strange to us because
here in our culture and you ask what
another one of these big changes are
according to the bmj and we're talking
top top tier peerreview
Journal approximately 60% of the average
American adults diet is now made of
Ultra Pro processed foods all right
humans have been processing Foods
forever for thousands of years cooking a
food is processing the food whether it's
cooking a steak making a sweet potato
taking olives and pressing pressing the
oil out that's all processing but those
are minimally processed they're not
denatured so much that you can still
tell where they come from they still
have a essence of something real Ultra
processed foods on the other hand is
when you see a field of Wheat and
somehow someway that becomes [__]
Pop-Tarts you see that field of Wheat
and it becomes Frosted Flakes right it's
like where if I was to present that box
of Pop-Tarts or those frosted flakes to
someone living in Cambodia or like a
rice Patty in Thailand and just like
where did this come
from they're not GNA have any clue at
all because it's like it's not real that
doesn't come from anything real and so
not to mention the processing that it
takes yes but let's not forget about all
of these newly invented synthetic
ingredients that are added along the way
how's this impact our sleep oh such a
good question this is such a good
question so there's two really
interesting things that is coming out in
the data so one part is what we're not
getting all right there are certain you
can have get sleep in darkness you can
have the most fancy pants mattress
you can you can check all the boxes for
all the things but if you're deficient
in the key nutrients that build your
sleep related hormones and
neurotransmitters you are still going to
have disrupted Sleep Quality if you
don't have the stuff that literally
builds the stuff that makes the magic
happen you're going to have problems and
I saw this again and again and again
working with real people in the real
world just for example vitamin C so so a
lot of folks of course we know about
vitamin C for your immune system all
right now that is putting vitamin C in a
very py box it's responsible for so many
things for our skin Health it's a big
contributor for our skin Health but it
is a huge contributor to our Sleep
Quality and one study was published in
PL one Public Library of science one and
they uncovered that folks with a vitamin
C deficiency were more prone to
disrupted sleep they didn't have
problems falling asleep but they had
problems staying asleep and so knowing
this what we tend to do is like I want
to make sure that I'm getting my vitamin
C in and we get a vitamin C
supplement I went to a conventional
University I had the big Auditorium
nutritional science class I paid for
this [__] I paid for this miseducation
I'm about to tell you in that class we
were taught very rudimentary things and
first and foremost based on the food
pyramid all right so I went to college
in the late 90s right that's when I
first went to
college and within this they said you
know my teacher would be like get the
Hallmark of the diet 7 to 11 servings of
healthy whole grains and make sure also
that you recommend for yourself and
patients if you work with people to take
a multivitamin to get all your vitamins
and minerals and so I was taught that
vitamin C is one thing and I can just
get it from this multivitamin of course
there's vitamin C and Foods as well but
what we were not taught and what most
people unfortunately have not realize
and that's changing today in this
conversation is that there isn't just
one form of vitamin C there are multiple
forms of vitamin C there are multiple
forms of B12 multiple forms of vitamin D
the list goes on and on multiple forms
and we're we just know maybe like 5% of
what's in food now there's so much we
don't know so the question is are you
getting the vitamin C that is actually
usable by your
C now here's where this gets a little
bit
sticky so looking for that vitamin C to
support our immune system or Sleep
Quality a lot of times we'll grab those
little packets you know those little
Energy emergency
whatever and we don't realize that over
90% of the vitamin C products sold in
the United States are made from
genetically modified corn starch and
corn syrup it's Ultra processed in every
sense of the word and one of the studies
that actually share in my new book The
eatsmarter Family cookbook looked at
what happens when we're taking real
whole food based vitamin C versus
synthetic and this was published in the
Journal of C Cardiology the Journal of
Cardiology and so what they did was they
took people who were doing a behavior
that would cause a lot of inflammation
and oxidative stress namely smoking
shout out to smoking Mark all right
namely smoking all right and so they
take these test subjects and they give
them a concentrate of vitamin C in the
form of this really I I superfood has
been really drugged through the mud all
right truly this is the most vitamin c
dense food ever discovered so if
anything's going to fit in this category
it's Camu Camu Berry c muu c muu so they
used a whole food based concentrate of
Camu Camu or a conventional vitamin C
synthetic
supplement so they're continuing their
behavior they're checking their
biomarkers they tracked their data for a
week they found that when the test
subjects took the real whole food based
vitamin
they had a significant reduction in
inflammatory biomarkers you know things
like C reactive protein oxidative stress
and there were no changes with the
synthetic run-of-the-mill vitamin C
supplement it didn't impact them at all
and as a matter of fact that synthetic
form of vitamin C and this is another
study that I mentioned in the book as
well doubles the incidence of developing
kidney stones all right so the question
is can my cells Rel
to this nutrient is it real is it
recognizable just because the chemistry
is the same does not mean that they are
the same in the human body we evolved
interacting with food chemistry but
today we have all of these isolated
synthetic versions of things and it
simply doesn't function the same way I
think a lot of people are pretty well
aware or at least they've got an idea
they're supposed to have a morning
routine right whether it's the 15
minutes of sunlight in the eyes and the
cold plunge and the grounding and the
meditation and the breath work and all
that sort of stuff far fewer people have
a cool down sequence at the end of the
day an evening time routine if you were
to give the big movers for somebody who
just spends a typical amount of time
doing typical things sometime on the
phone sometime on the screen exercise
and adequate amount but it's not insane
they're not a professional athlete what
would you say when do you begin getting
ready for bed for sleep time what are
the dos and what are the don'ts and how
big is this territory of time leading up
to bed what would you how would you
prescribe someone's pre-sleep ritual Oo
we could get the sexiest juiciest sleep
of Our Lives if we follow what I'm about
to share it starts with dinner it starts
with dinner that evening routine because
the dinner table is
potentially the most powerful down
regulator of that kind of sympathetic
fight ORF flight nervous system and this
is based on some of the strongest signs
that we have period I'll share sh two
quick studies one of them was a
colleague of mine Dr Robert waldinger we
had a f okay Robert waldinger there you
go he is the the director of the longest
running longitudinal human study on
longevity and their data indicates that
Beyond beating obesity Beyond exercise
great diet all the things and these
things matter the number one determinant
on how long we're going to live is the
quality of our
relationships couple that with a new
study that I highlighted in the E marter
family cookbook conducted by research
that bringham Young University they this
was a meta analysis of 148 studies
300,000 people and they found that our
relationships led to having healthy
relationships or what they called
healthy social bonds led to a 50%
reduction in all cause mortality so that
means a 50% reduction in Death from
everything you know prematurely and so
there's something special about human
interaction and relationships and what
it really is just a sidebar is that our
relationship
more than anything influence what we eat
it influences our sleep habits it
influences our exercise habits how we
relate to ourselves what we think about
ourselves how we feel our emotional
stability it's the tip of the spear and
so here's how all of this ties together
around the dinner table the dinner table
really functions as a unifier to bring
people together this is something we
evolved doing into the
evening we're even even in tribal
constructs and if anybody's been to
Hawaii for example they do this kind of
dramatization of a luau right this the
Kiki Beach I've seen the exact thing
there you go like we we did this hunt we
got this food you know we're all dining
together we're telling stories that's
really how human history has passed
along before the Advent of books and
we're celebrating right through our
Evolution we hunted gathered together
procured our food together prepared the
food ate together and celebrated
together that was the time of human
bonding it's deeply ingrained in our DNA
we expect that our genes expect us to do
this and so this is where dinner is the
first Domino because when we're eating
with people that we care about friends
and families as well family and friends
are
included there's this really remarkable
switching over from the sympathetic
fight ORF flight to the parasympathetic
nervous system that's what the data is
indicating which is so exciting one of
the reasons is we start to produce more
oxytocin right and so oxytocin
it's got a couple of nicknames cuddle
hormone love hormone but why it really
matters in this context is that it's
been found to neutralize cortisol so to
help us to
downregulate and we're very good we're
very very good at going zero to 100 all
right real quick shout out to Drake but
we're not very good at going 100 to zero
at all being with people that we love
does something for our nervous systems
to help us to downregulate faster than
anything so take advantage of that and
how does this play out in the data do I
have any data to affirm this you know I
do all right so really quickly I'm going
rattle these off researchers at Harvard
tracked human eating Behavior family
eating behavior and food intake all
right for years and when I found this
data I was like why doesn't anybody know
this and so they found that people who
eat together with their family on a
regular basis have dramatically higher
intake of real whole unprocessed Foods
and by Nature significantly higher
intake of vital nutrients that prevent
chronic diseases and help us sleep
better by the way and those family
members consumed significantly less
Ultra processed foods namely chips and
soda what about for kids published in
the journal Pediatrics they found that
eating with our children just three
meals per week or more but three is that
effect minimum effective dose which I'm
a big fan of knowing that we want change
but we don't want to change that much
eating with our kids three times a week
led to dramatically reduced incidents of
those children developing obesity and
eating disorders what about for us as
adults Tech workers at IBM were tracked
looking at their family eating Behavior
around dinner being able to quote make
it home for dinner regardless of how
much stress they were experiencing at
work if they were able to consistently
eat dinner with their families their
stress remained negligible it was
manageable it was neutralized work more
and productivity stayed high stress
stayed manageable but as soon as things
started cutting into their ability to
eat dinner with their families stress
levels be went up exceedingly High work
morale went down productivity goes down
all right there's something special
about eating together with with people
that you care about I mentioned oxytocin
I mentioned the switch over to the
parasympathetic here's the key word
tying all this together the nickname of
the parasympathetic nervous system is
rest
rest and
digest do you hear me that is that's the
nickname of this part of the nervous
system and this is a binary system it's
either this or that it's it's on or off
you're either in sympathetic
parasympathetic and so switching over
being with people that we care about
especially under the context of good
food it is incredibly special last part
here is the psychological benefits to be
able to help to to to offload and
downregulate when you are feeling seen
we have a deep human need for
significance and being able to see your
child or your loved one and for them to
feel like they matter versus you know
what we're doing now is this because not
only did we devolve from tribes to
neighborhoods well we start to get more
separate but when neighborhoods were the
Advent of that we still had extended
family in close
proximity then we started to get
isolated Rel ated to our nuclear family
only and then in just in the last couple
of decades as we leaned into this whole
conversation we've become even more
divided within our own household because
of our devices our devices have divided
us and not to villainize these things of
course but we need to keep them in
context we need real FaceTime with real
people well my video guy before we got
started was telling me there's a meme
going around the internet that I haven't
seen yet but that um like how would guys
be able to eat if they didn't turn
YouTube on
like that what you need to do is turn
YouTube on in order for you to then
begin eating your food right and I
remember uh an ex-girlfriend of mine
from ages and ages ago told me this
story about one of her exes the first
time that he'd come around for food with
her family and he'd sat down and they
were all sat around the table and he
took his plate off the table onto his
lap to eat it on his lap because he was
so conditioned to his family sitting on
the couch and watching the te watch
watching the TV and eating food from his
lap so he was sat at a dining table with
no TV there had to slide back and put
the the plate on his lap which is just
such a funny bit of conditioning that he
obviously didn't see but to everybody
else sat around the table was like this
is crazy um but yeah I I see it in
myself uh um Dr K healthy gamer who is a
uh
psychiatrist classically trained in
Western medicine but also did four or
five years in e medicine too so he's got
this really lovely holistic View and he
has a fantastic Community for young guys
and girls that are into gaming some of
them have got screen addictions some of
them don't but it's it's mental health
for you know young people that use the
internet a lot and him and Hamza another
kid from the UK started doing Zoom calls
daily Zoom calls so that people could
just eat food with other people M
interesting so they would jum jump on a
call and sometimes people would say
nothing they'd just have a scream with a
bunch of faces and they would do it
together because it's all well and good
saying being around people that you love
uh being with your family so on and so
forth like I moved away from the country
that I was born in I'd love to eat food
with my mom and dad but if they'd have
to be up at midnight in order to be able
to even FaceTime me I've got my
housemate so yeah I can do it with him
but I do think that it's just so
interesting to look at the solutions
that people are coming up with to try
and recreate what it is that you're
suggesting that they do let's just slow
down a little bit I'm going to guess as
well that you would tell me that if you
have to try and have a
conversation in between bites of food
that it's going to slow down the pace at
which you eat which is going to reduce
satiety it's going to ensure that you
chew your food properly which is going
to make it easier to digest it's going
to give you more breath between it which
is going to mean that your digestion has
got more time to you know all of these
different things it's a full stack of
improvement uh around what you do and
then maybe everyone's sick of spending
time indoors and goes why don't we go
for a little walk once we finish up and
the whole family goes for a walk and
then you get all the benefits of the
10-minute walk there's no supplement
that can do all the things you just
mentioned there's no drug that can do
all the things you just mentioned these
are things that our jeans expect us to
do you know that's the really remarkable
part about it so of course we do want to
find some some transitionary tools like
being able to talk on FaceTime or
whatever the case might be but when I
walked in here you were eating with your
boys you guys were hanging out eating
eating some food but it's those moments
you know but of course it might be a
little bit rushed it might be this and
that but there's something about taking
a moment to pause and just be present
eat and connect with people when it
comes to timing here I remember and it's
something that I follow just because
it's easy to remember a 321 rule for
Sleep 3 hours before sleeping no more
food 2 hours before eating try and limit
fluids and then 1 hour before uh 2 hours
before sleeping try and limit fluids 1
hour before sleeping uh try and limit
light when it comes to us going from
eating on an evening time have you got a
rough uh rule that you try to follow
between uh food time and sleep time and
then let's continue this sexiest night
of sleep of your life protocol all the
way up to getting into bed yeah that's a
great question so um this is going to be
situationally dependent it's going to be
unique because there are some folks and
now we have the Advent of like you know
continuous glucose monitors where you
could track this if I eat too far out
from dinner for myself I notice that my
blood sugar goes significantly low at
night and it can pull me out of sleep
all right so and I'm talking about like
more than five hours before sleep which
doesn't seem that's not a lot of time
and so for me it's like finishing my
last bite of food maybe 2 to three hours
before I go to bed is IDE deal for me
personally now I've done all kinds of
stuff again 21 years being at this level
I've experimented a lot so I've done all
kinds of fasts I've done 21 days I've
done all kinds of stuff I don't want
anybody have to go through but I found
it I found my way to sleep like your
body will sort stuff out but you got to
find what's optimal for you all right so
and to transition into this from the
dinner table where where we left off and
by the way all of those studies are
featured in the new East martyr family
cookbook there's over 250 scientific
references in a cookbook which has never
been done but then also we talk about
what are we eating so that we can get
those good sleep nutrients in and I'll
just throw this out here really quickly
there's well I'll share two really
quickly one of them dark cherries all
right there there are a couple of
studies looking at cherry juice as an
Implement for improving Sleep Quality
but that the sugar can be a little bit
you know that can be sketchy but a
couple of the studies I Shar in the book
first of all cherries are one of the
most dense sources
of naturally occurring melatonin of any
food cherries are dark cherries in
particular pretty rich in
melatonin on top of that one of the
studies looked at the anthocyanins in
these cherries and found that it they
can have the potential to shrink fat
cells and so it's cool like you found
this stuff and I put my Emojis next to
every kind of benefit so like for the
metabolic Health like The Fat Loss
there's like a little muscle Emoji
there's a sleep Emoji there then you go
back to Associated food like okay what
do I do to eat this food and we've got
like a couple of you know cool recipes
one of them is a cherry frozen yogurt
pop that you can have after dinner um my
kids love it and they're fun it's like
fun stuff to make too and they're very
simple that's another thing about this
is making it easy as well I don't want a
recipe that's got 37 ingredients like
let's just make this simple delicious
and there you go but another food which
is really a great kind of nighttime
routine and there are many and you don't
want to necessarily eat this dish every
night but salmon is really really
something special when it comes to
improving and supporting Sleep Quality
Salmon's got a moment in the sun right
now for sure a lot of people are aware
of some of the benefits but those
Omega-3s are one of those things where a
deficiency in Omega-3s is clinically
shown to disrupt our sleep cycles all
right so it's not just this like oh it's
good for your brain no no no like
seriously your brain needs these
Omega-3s they're responsible for
creating structural fats in the body not
as energy but like to build rebuild and
support your brain cells so they can
talk to each other it's kind of
important and one of the studies used
fmis and tracked people's like actually
looked at their brains which is again
instead of guessing and they found that
people who ate less than four grams of
DHA and EPA these are animal-based
Omega-3s four grams or less had the
highest rate of brain
shrinkage four grams is that minimum
effect of dose and you can get that in a
high quality wild caught 8 O piece of
salmon and every we've all had nice
salmon filet that's great I've got I've
got a honey Sriracha salmon in in the
book which is great what about a salmon
burger All right so that's probably one
of my favorite foods right now are these
salmon burgers but like turning these
great sleep supporting Foods having
delicious food experiences have all the
dinner table benefits and now we
transition into the next thing and so
again this is going to I'm going to say
generally two to four hours before bed
to finish your last meal ideally for
most people but there there's going to
be outliers all right so now what do we
do do we get off do we finish dinner
let's say the goal is to go to bed at 10
p.m. just in this context and I finish
dinner at 7:30 all right no do I want to
go and jump right back on my screen
watch a show whatever I could that could
be part of my brain's reward like I
watch 30
minutes of a favorite show right or I go
and game with my son play 2K bust his
ass he's pretty good too right after
again creating that postmeal reward for
sitting down and eating together right
but now you might want to pop on some
blue light blocking glasses you know we
might want to do that so it's starting
to think about light pollution 3 hours
before bed it depends on the person but
I just that's why I put the word might
just rough rough H her round about three
hours before bed start thinking about
the light you're exposed yes exactly
start thinking about it at least and
then from there you know again if we're
popping back on whatever for me I'll
just tell you what it is for my kind of
light curfew is one hour it is and I've
I might be the person who's impressed
that in popular culture because again I
wrote about this almost 10 years ago um
at least
that's the that's the minimum for me
ideally 90 minutes to 2 hours ideally I
think a lot of people would have a
question of okay especially now right
we're approaching uh winter uh you guys
uh are losing daylight savings that's
just that's getting axed uh evening
times get dark pretty early yeah and the
more Northerly you get I'm from
Newcastle in the northeast of the UK
which is the last City before Scotland
so around about December mid December
time it can be sunset at 400 p.m. right
so it's it's really dark all the time
it's not Sunrise until after 8 so it's
very very very short amount of time how
am I supposed to
exist I don't want to bump into things
right I've got fear I'm also this let's
be real here I don't want to be bored I
don't want to be bored for the last 90
minutes of every single day if I want to
uh you're saying it's probably a bad
idea for me to watch a screen but if I
read a book I need a light to light the
book is an e-reader going to disrupt my
Cadian Rhythm can I use my Kindle what
if it's on warm like what can people do
to actually enjoy the last two hours of
their day if they also need to be
conscious of the light pollution I love
this this is what really I think is has
made my teaching of this information
more relatable and doable is because
we've got to we've got to put the
neurotic Behavior to the side all right
and we all especially when we're working
to get healthy and to achieve certain
things we do go through a phase I think
everybody does of being neurotic about
these things we've got to chill we live
in the modern world and there's stuff
there's stuff going on and there are
certain things that can help us enjoy
that stuff even more if we feel better
and
so if we can create an evening routine
for the majority of the time that works
for us where we still can do some of our
favorite things because that's what life
is all about as well we've got to get
that juice well yeah what's the point in
optimizing your sleep if you sacrifice
the enjoyment of your spare time in
order to get it like what's the point of
getting good sleep presumably so that
you enjoy life and if you sacrifice the
enjoyment of life to sleep well in the
hopes that sleeping well will give you
an enjoyment of life like you're
shortcutting everything exactly you just
said it perfectly you know so we've got
to come into this with some balance with
a balanced perspective and give
ourselves some Grace and some wiggle
room and some enjoyment and if we can do
little things like again throwing on
some blue light black and glasses we do
have do you have any brands that you
prefer I want to throw Brands out okay
well raw Optics Matt Maroa from raws go
boom I I like raw Optics I know that
he's done an awful lot of research
they're not cheap but it seems like a
lot of the blue blocking glasses that
are cheap that don't have a very heavily
colored lens if you can still see all of
the normal colors with a little bit of a
a blue tinge that's not really doing
very much according to him you need to
be it needs to be like offensively
colored and you can get them in yellow
or red and I noticed anecdotally if I
put them on I know this is the same with
some of my other friendss any high
quality blue blocking
glasses after about 30 minutes you
almost feel this down regulation yep
interesting a palpable effect that I
noticed and I was using it in the UK
remembering that it gets dark early in
the summer uh in the winter but in the
summer it really overcooks it so you can
have sun set at 10:30 at night uh so for
me I would pop them on and go for an
evening walk maybe 9:30 and I would find
while I was on this walk I would get
this down regulation so we're looking at
some blue blocking glasses again if
we're going to be exposed to light yeah
I've got I have some from him as well Y
and you know and you just said it
there's going to be a varying degree of
how effective this is but also part of
it can be the neuro Association as well
to putting those on and because that's
one of the things that I noticed
definitely early on in testing these
things that as soon as I popped them on
I started to get a little bit sleepier
you know and human the human brain is
always looking for a routine it's always
looking to automate behaviors and so
what's said is that neurons that fire
together wire together and so that
behavior of like I'm having this evening
routine I care about my sleep I'm giving
it some respect I'm popping these on I'm
still you know dabbling and you know
watching a show or you know doing a
little bit of stuff on my phone I
mentioned playing a video game with my
kid right now we have to look at the
other part of the stimulation though
right and so this is where we do want to
have give yourself that screen curfew of
at least an hour to just like get off of
the screens do something else and by the
way there's thousands of other things
you could do all right but we just like
ah you know so there's thousands of
other things that we can do and I'm
going to share a couple with you so you
mentioned like reading a book yes we can
have some dim light you know read a book
read a re there real books are still out
here on the streets they still do exist
but even more so this is a good time to
just if you can chat with somebody you
don't have to stare at a phone or a
screen to to talk with somebody that you
care about if you're not in person but
if you're in a relationship for example
and you're in the house together this is
a great time for my wife and I just to
chat catch up talk and also one of the
chapters in sleep smarter which it just
happened to be on page 69 was about sex
I didn't know somebody who bought the
book told me they were like Sean is
slick you think he's slick but it was
talking about orgasm and how that
impacts Sleep Quality and so we've got
some kind of um cultural memes about
people falling asleep whatever
afterwards well like seriously you're
producing a cocktail of different
chemicals chemistry that does support
Sleep Quality
significantly um we've got I mentioned
oxytocin before we've got prolactin for
example and men one of the studies that
I mentioned in the book actually produce
like four times more prolactin when they
have an orgasm with their partner versus
having one by themselves wow prolactin
is very very heavy for optimizing
improving Sleep Quality making people
sleepy that's part of the reason even
like the going another round is like the
prolactin equation and so what's so
interesting here is that by the way like
some people like you know have with a
partner I go right to sleep versus like
by myself I go eat a bowl of cereal yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so you've
been watching
me and so just understanding that the
Big O is the chap the name of that
chapter
does in fact again in that time Gap
maybe you could have sex yeah that
hopefully hopefully that's better than
you know I don't know Yellowstone yeah
or whatever else you know people are
watching but um you know just with that
just being able to invest in your
relationship which is again that pays
back so much and that's just I'm just
throwing out a couple of things there
are so many things that we can do have
you got any insights a lot of the people
that are listening to this may uh listen
to podcasts when they fall asleep I
sometimes find if I'm listening to
something that is
too cerebrally compelling and demanding
that it puts me into a kind of sort of
lean in uh curiosity State on an evening
time uh whereas if I get some nice uh
fiction or some narrative non-fiction uh
I like um you know stories of History
documentaries about
stuff like World War II and bits and
pieces like that uh that to me kind of
puts me into more of a what feels like a
narrative story mode that feels like it
primes me more for sleep have you ever
is there any data to back any of this
stuff there absolutely is fantastic I
knew it wasn't bro signs yeah
specifically fiction you know reading
fiction listening to this is how we
evolved is having those stories in the
evening like our genes it's an input
it's something we've done for a long
time and and we have this
cultural you know kind of iconic thing
of like reading your kids a bedtime
story we're just big adult babies if you
really boil down to it but instead of a
nice bedtime story now we're just
stressed like we're just thinking about
all kinds of [__] to stress us out
instead of giving ourselves the
opportunity to like let me switch over
like literally our brain is functioning
differently when we are engaged in story
you know and so absolutely there's some
really cool signs it's already been
affirmed on that but also you know this
is an opportunity too as you just
mentioned I love that of listening to a
podcast as well because you don't have
to stare at a screen to listen to a
podcast the same thing holds true with
there are people eating lunch right now
watching us oh yeah all right and Shout
out if you are leave a comment down
below tell us what you're eating what
you EA yeah exactly was it from the cook
was it from the new cookbook oh right if
that part if you're from eating
something from the new cookbook but the
thing is I've been known especially on a
lunch break to like pop on something on
YouTube like you know Co Conan O'Brien
Clips or something brandom thing you
know and so again it's not to be
neurotic and I've structured my life in
a way I've created a micr culture in my
household where I have real FaceTime and
eat together with the people that I care
about on a regular basis so it's a it's
a both-end world this is the point we
don't have to be either or we don't have
to you know like be completely a a a a
tech addict or a lite y it's a both and
world what we do need to do is listen to
our bodies listen to our minds
acknowledge where we are feeling this
kind of dysfunction or turbulence within
our spirit because often times it's like
a guidance system because there are
certain inputs that we are missing out
on and other inputs that we might be
getting too much of one of the things
it's funny that you mentioned
the ancestral disposition that we have
or The evolutionary sort of priming that
we have to hear stories around the
campfire before we're about to go to
sleep uh and this is absolutely Bro
Science but if someone wants to do the
study on it it works for me radio dramas
as they're called technically so a full
cast rendition of a story um there's my
favorite author fiction author pce Brown
uh who does Red Rising is slowly
releasing all of his books in full
unabridged but with an entire cast and
this is soundscape with all of the
sounds and it's so immersive and there's
a different character for each voice and
I find those to be if I really really
want to fall asleep if I'm on a plane or
if I want to do whatever if I drop into
one of those it's it's it's outrageous
and I wonder whether that almost mimics
in some regards the typical campfire uh
suround rounding um but yeah I mean from
my side that sort of falling asleep
listening to something I the problem is
as with a lot of the issues of
Technology it's so compelling that it
can actually start to push that sleep
window further and further away right I
one more chapter one more whatever right
so the discipline to be able to say no
to it is also again neither the Lite nor
the addict it's somewhere somewhere in
between um what about
this is something I think which is a
very very common issue and hopefully
earlier in the day people have exercised
got sunlight done all of the things to
Wi
down even having done all of that I've
noticed periods in my life where I
struggle to fall asleep if somebody is
regularly getting into bed and having
you know an hour plus of latency before
they're able to fall asleep what are the
what are the first few culprits or
places that you would be looking at in
order to
try and optimize this all right the it's
like the Matrix right now there's
there's a hundred different things that
it could be you rank go to the top five
it's it's going to be situation
dependent I I'll rank some of them but
even with you mentioning that the the
full cast and the story the ancient
tenant is to know thyself know thyself
like that's top tier importance because
we're so unique and so I just want to
throw in a little parenthesis as well of
like by the way it doesn't have to be a
fiction it could be a personal
development thing it could be a sermon
it could be whatever helps you to make
that transition in into sleep whatever
works for you give yourself some space
and some Grace to to try some different
things now with sleep latency so I'm
going to tell you the first thing period
and you know this is it encompasses so
much but often times it's just stress
it's excessive stress and us not
metabolizing that stress efficiently
what you mean when when you say
metabolizing stress so being able
to you know cortisol for example has
kind of been drug through the mud and
giv this bad name but cortisol is not
bad it's I like to think of it like the
Incredible Hulk you know it's like yes
it can smash some [__] and like but also
it can get stuff done it is powerful it
gets us up and going and it can get a
little bit out of hand especially if
there's a lot of Hulk you know and so we
need Hulk to turned back into Bruce
Banner basically this is a great analogy
I just came up with that one just now
all right and so to downregulate
actually in the movie The First Avengers
movie uh Scarlett Johansson's
character uh black widow she would do
this little kind of uh rhyme like this
little kind of song this little kind of
technique to help the big guy to
downregulate and soothe him and bring
him back down all right A lot of times
we just kind of running too hot we've
got a lot of adrenaline you know
epinephrine norepinephrine cortisol is
not the only stress hormone but we've
got a lot of that just pumping through
our system based on our thoughts our
thoughts create chemistry in our bodies
instantaneously and a lot of times one
of my really good friends Dr Daniel aan
he calls them ants automatic negative
thoughts and we just get on these Loops
of these you know things that can just
weigh on our spirit we've got to be able
to
when I say metabolize really I'm talking
about to to to neutralize to shift gears
over to that
parasympathetic and it it depends on you
what that's going to be what the
treatment's going to be so this could be
a simple change in perception you know
sometimes it's just a reality check and
I'm a big fan of that one personally
which is like I might be thinking about
the 10 things that I need to get done
like I just did Good Morning America uh
a couple days ago and I was in with my
publisher the day before and she was
just like so you know are you excited da
d da and she's just like I would be a
nervous wreck I don't even know how hey
thanks hey real good pep talk but for me
it's just like because I just don't
perceive it like she does and if I was
to be like oh my God I gotta I gotta I
have I have a very short window of time
I got to get up super early and I need
to
whatever I'm just going to be like
there's nothing I could do about it
right now chill just it doesn't
matter I I'm here in my bed none of that
matters just chill so I could I know how
to speak to myself you know and again
it's a reality check for me that these
things that I'm might be pining over
there's and here's a really cool thing
too is that it's during sleep that so
much of our problems are solved and if
we got some really cool data on this um
even Rim sleep in particular in dreaming
like dreaming is some freaky stuff man
you know and we we we think we've got
some good ideas about what's happening
but during Rim sleep we know that this
process called memory consolidation is
taking place so like things from our
short short-term memory kind of like or
from the day of getting converted to our
short-term memory and being becoming
more retrievable but also there's just
kind of like play as we're playing out
it's kind of like our brain in a way is
keeping us entertained while it's fixing
[__] and one of the things that I do and
I'm just going to share this tip another
way to to
downregulate is if I'm if I'm dealing
with the problem I'm not just going to
sit there with it and worry about it and
this is from thinking Grow Rich Napoleon
Hill and it changed my life years ago
and actually the person who introduced
me to is Bob Proctor and I had multiple
conversations with him it's just like
man just to even say that stuff coming
from where I come from to be able to
share time with people like that is
mind-blowing but I I have have a meeting
with my board of trusted advisers so as
I'm laying in bed if for example it's a
challenge with uh let's just give an
example of if it's somebody with their
health all right if they're wanting to
deal with a health issue they can pick
maybe you know a table like a long table
like this and there's three people on
one side three people on the other and
who are those trusted advisers that
would sit at your table to offer you
counsel you know maybe this might be um
you know um Andrew huberman maybe this
might be Dr Daniel aan neuroscientist
maybe this might I I might be at the
table with you and then on the other
side maybe it's like you know your
friend who's really into health or
whatever the case might be and then you
just go through and you ask them what
what is their opinion on what you should
do to get better or to feel better
because the thing is you already know
what they're going to [__] say you
know what they're going to say but
sitting down and doing this practice and
allowing them to speak to you through
your mind is so remarkable well the
depersonalization of that tactic right
of removing yourself from being both
judge jury
executioner uh the the the evidence
gatherer and the person that is supposed
to coordinate this entire charade yeah
is so important like I've got written on
my on my fridge what would you tomorrow
want you today to do and the reason that
it's so useful is it gives you that
perspective just a tiny tiny little bit
of distance between what's happening now
and what's happening tomorrow and what
you would want to do and yeah I like
that okay so we've got um looking at the
stresses the kind of uh open Loops that
as of yet we haven't finding a way for
yourself yep to help to metabolize a
stress to downregulate instead of you
know going into the you know the r i I
think that most people when they're
trying to fall asleep and struggling
what's happening is they will ruminate
aggressively very few people are
struggling to fall asleep while their
mind is perfectly peaceful and blank
yeah right they are
uh trying to keep their heart rate low
whilst doing very intense exercise all
mentally right I'm trying to keep myself
calm and yet I'm doing the opposite
thing of keeping myself calm and very
active is there anything else are there
any of the other main culprits for this
uh sleep latency issue absolutely
so just to put a cherry on top of that
again stress is the number one thing and
it comes in many different forms and
Fashions so finding something for
yourself to process all of that inner
chatter that's what my my mother-in-law
uh calls it she gave me that lexicon you
got a lot of inner chatter and this
could be something usually it's actually
going to be before you get into bed by
the way and I want to offer up so here's
another way is to do a form of
meditation even you know if anything
because with meditation is one of those
ways we can kind of glimpse into Theta
and Delta potentially like if you're
really skilled meditator but this is a
way so we can kind of start to tip the
scales into more like
anabolic in a sleep is truly the
anabolic state that we're in but we can
kind of tiptoe our way into it ideally
because of the neuro Association you
might not want to do that in bed itself
but you can know thyself oh right so
you're saying the bed is to be reserved
for sleeping and having sex rule over
again we're not watching TV we're not
working we're not doing the thing yeah I
like that but if a meditation in bed
like there's a body scanning meditation
you can go down and tense and relax and
that kind of thing you could do that in
bed but know yourself if doing a
meditation in bed might not transition
you to sleep the way that you want and I
love a meditation for if we wake up and
have trouble falling back asleep to lay
and just yeah just try to keep bringing
your attention back to your breath all
right um but also okay so what can be
another thing with sleep
latency outside of stress the other
thing which is a form of stress is is
nutrient
deficiencies period all right again you
can have the best sleep routine if
you're not providing your body with
those raw those raw materials those
building blocks to help with the
conversion of Serotonin into melatonin
which serotonin is the prerequisite for
making melatonin by the way that all has
to do most of your serotonin is is in
your gut and
so what are the things that you're doing
nutritionally that can be screwing up
that process what the Sleep superfoods o
good question I mentioned cherries
earlier y That's a top tier uh good
sleep food salmon another top tier good
sleep food and I'm going to share
another one with you that you know it's
one of these Foods been around for a
long time but and also it has number one
the Omega-3s are there as well eggs
great we identify it often times for as
like a morning food it's not the fact of
any of these Foods you're just going to
eat and fall asleep all right but eggs
are remarkable in the the choline
choline is involved in the Sleep process
as well and those Omega-3s are really
helpful and also just amino acids
because when we're talking
about when I've said hormones and
neurotransmitters several times
today these are essentially cellular DMS
all right it's enabling your cells to
talk to each other that's what a hormone
is and at its core hormones are proteins
if you're deficient in certain amino
acids you can't even make that [__]
anyways so your body will do a patchwork
job but if you provide your body with
the amino acids it needs to build those
things you're going to be in a much
better favor okay another one tryp thean
all right tryptophan that's where it
gets the association with the what we
call from where I'm from itis like being
sleepy after you eat food especially on
Thanksgiving and the turkey and all the
things yes turkey is a rich source of
tryptophan but there are you know
certain plant Foods as well but yeah
turkey we'll just put throw that on the
list there so chicken turkey is a song
that has that in it but those are going
to be a couple of other ones because
tryptophan amino acid all right and it's
deeply involved in our sleep process and
so what is that is that four of them
five cherries
salmon
tryptophan and turkey okay we said
Turkey already next yes let me give you
a
drink there's so many here again we're
not talking about guzzling a a pint of
water we're talking about like a a
serving of like a teacup we know about
chamomile for down regulating for
relaxing we know about kavak Cava one of
my favorites is Rishi Rishi te a dual
extracted Rish so this study was
published in the journal pharmacology
biochemistry and behavior and the
researchers found that that drinking
Rishi just prior of bedtime we could say
an hour before bedtime 30 minutes an
hour maybe a little bit longer was able
to number one improve sleep latency
meaning you fall asleep faster it
improved overall sleep time and it
improved the quality of test subjects
sleep namely improving their non- RM
deep sleep time all right so that's
pretty remarkable and rishi's been
utilized for thousands of years do you
have a bronze do you prefer for that for
sigmatic my gu's for sigmatic it's a
dual extraction of the Rishi that's why
primarily so that means it's an alcohol
extract and a hot water extract because
different things are going to get pulled
out of the mushroom based on the
extraction method and if you're just
getting one you can be missing out on
like the hot water extract get a lot of
these antioxidant components beta
glucans things like that but the alcohol
extract can get some of these more
hormonally uh pointed compounds you've
mentioned the window the how important
is eggs does eggs have to be later in
the evening does salmon have to be later
in the evening does it's just throughout
the day we can create the building
blocks that are good for school exactly
your body knows what to do to to store
things away when it needs cool Okay so
we've looked at stress and we've looked
at nutrients I think that those are two
pretty big movers we've already touched
on some of the new work that you've done
your book came out this week
congratulations um talk to me about the
current state of American adults Health
from a a metabolic and a weight
perspective all right this was by this
was published by the CDC in 2022 so just
about a year ago as of this recording
they determined that 60% of American
adults now have at least one chronic
disease at least one and 40% have two or
more all right so just a kind of
overarching perspective look at this now
one of our top tier journals that's
looking at metabolic Health recently
published some data and it's been making
the making the rounds on on the internet
and they established that only 12% of
American adults are metabolically
healthy so 88% of adults are not
metabolically healthy and this is
looking at certain biomarkers you know
whether we're talking about hormones
whether we're talking about the role of
insulin and leptin and the list goes on
and on and so now to to what does this
look like in the real world like what do
we see well prior to pandemic related
shutdowns we were at about
42.5 % of American adults being
clinically obese and it was projected to
reach 50% by
2030 but when things shut down there was
a mighty jump the data hasn't come out
yet completely but we're we're probably
very close to that 50% already and if
we're talking about overweight and
obesity then we're looking at about 75%
of the population right now
something dramatic has happened
because and also we can't leave out kids
in this convers ation by the way there
was a study published in the New England
Journal of Medicine and it looked at 200
years of diabetes as a title of the
paper and essentially di type two
diabetes which used to be called adult
onset diabetes because kids didn't get
that [__] but now a lot of kids younger
and younger and younger populations are
getting heart disease are getting
diabetes are developing obesity and so
but it was within about a 40e time span
just like in the last 40 to 50
years rates of type 2 diabetes
essentially quadrupled in the US
population and along with that childhood
obesity just in the last 30 years has
tripled all right let alone us as adults
like this is trickling its way down to
our little ones which is incredibly
abnormal and so just a couple of other
Quick
stats um I mentioned earlier about the
sleep deprivation stat but right now our
number one our leading cause of death is
is still heart
disease and I got to throw this in here
as well a lot of people don't know this
but Alzheimer's is number six it is just
charging up into the top five leading
causes of death in the United States
it's an epidemic and it is scary and a
lot of times we don't think about like
how is that killing people like loss of
our cognitive function like that man
like that is such a terrible way to die
and researchers are now calling
Alzheimer's type 3 diabetes
because it's so related to insulin
dysfunction in the brain that's
literally what Max said yeah that's
literally what Max said yeah and so I
wanted to mention that but heart disease
being the number one killer now
according to again published data about
60% of American adults have some degree
of heart disease onset already like that
can be that can be
tracked simple blood test we could see
okay you're on your way to die from a
heart attack is the most common
precursor to heart disease obesity or or
being overweight that's a great question
there's definitely some interplay here
let's talk about obesity because you
know right now we're living at a time
where people are there's a framing
around obesity and working as a
clinician and working with real people
who are struggling with their weight for
many years A lot of people are try they
are trying very very very hard to lose
that weight but they're existing in a
culture that is fighting against them
and so we placed a lot of judgment
cognitively if we are healthy or of a
healthy weight and don't understand the
struggles of people who are really
trying hard now there are some people
who don't give a [__] and I'll tell you
what even with that even as I'm joking
about that I've never met one person who
doesn't want to be healthy if they had a
choice the person who app apparently
doesn't give a [__] and they're 350 lbs
if they had a choice they would be
healthy they would be of a healthy
weight they would have an ideal body and
energy and all the things they want what
happens is we develop something called
learned
helplessness on top of that we have
these stories like sometimes it's
literally
about worthiness it's about what's
possible for me it's about access it's
about money it's about all these things
my mother for example you know grew up
in a a low-income environment a lot of
times like my mom would sell her blood
she'd go to the blood bank sell her
blood get $20 and get us some fast food
a lot of times and she you know we got
food from Charities you know there's a
place called The Hosea house we get we
get food you know government assistance
all the things but she was working she
worked overnight at convenience store
and one of those nights somebody tried
to rob the store and she was stabbed
multiple
times but my mom is different she's
alive and well today
she actually detained the guy and he end
up getting arrested yeah I mean no I'm
not I'm not kidding at all I'm not
kidding at all man picked on the wrong
mother like listen I'm not kidding I got
I got so many stories listen I'm I'm
trying to I'm trying to hold back and
telling you some of the crazy [__] she's
done but here's here's why I'm sharing
this story is that when she went in for
you know surgery get the stitches and
all the things afterwards The Physician
was examining her and he said that if
you were not overweight he said these
these were his words if you weren't a
heavy set woman you probably would have
died because the depth of penetration of
the knife would have been closer to
vital organs so her story is my fat is
my
safety yeah I can see I can see how
that's a a double-edged sword for one of
a better term
damn so here's the thing too again we
have these stories and for some people
that excess that they're carrying is
protection maybe it's protection from an
as salent maybe it's a protection from a
family member maybe it's a protection
from attention unwanted
attention there are so many different
reasons why folks are in the state that
they're in and I want to remove the
judgment and just talk about the
biology fat cells are phenomenal it's
enabled us to be sitting here today is
because of our ancestors and these
badass fat
cells we evolved our capacity to utilize
stored energy in times of
famine and something a little fun fact
about our fat cells is that our fat
cells can actually grow and contain
about like a thousand times their own
volume like the the size of it itself a
thousand times its volume it can hold
energy essentially we didn't evolve
containing that much however but today
because we never have a famine we just
keep filling and filling and filling
these fat cells and what happens is we
start to have this unwanted immune
response because that the stress of that
fat cell getting expanded unnaturally
and never getting a chance to offload is
essentially sending out a false distress
signal to our immune system that this
cell is infected essentially you know
there's something abnormal happening
here and
as this is happening this is
contributing and we saw this even during
you know pandemic related things with a
significantly higher incidence of severe
outcomes hospitalizations and death when
we venture into obesity and a part of
that is the dysfunction that happens
with our immune system now on top of
that with the immune system dysfunction
what about cancer
because part of the ability of cancer to
progress is
an abnormal relationship with our immune
system and being able to catch Things
Early in our immune system to basically
take out Rogue cells that you know have
he reached the hay flick limit they're
not supposed to replicate all the things
and take that take them
out what we see in the data we see about
a
doubling doubling of the risk of breast
cancer doubling of a risk of prostate
cancer five times greater risk of colon
cancer seven times greater risk of
endometrial cancer when we develop
obesity it's crazy and so this is not
about vanity this is about a state of
our biology a state of our physiology a
state of human health that is subjecting
us to all manner of disease and
dysfunction so I like the input of
trying to remove the moralizing from
this it's what I learned from Max when I
first spoke to him last year and and
he he reminded me that there are lots of
different ways that people can get
fat uh good example of this Robert
Plowman the guy that did the largest
ever twin studies in the world uh every
single pair of twins born between 1991
and 1994 in the UK was contacted about
being enrolled in his study he's the
father of behavioral genetics and he was
talking to me and he was saying that he
has the predisposition to be fat and he
said that when he walks past a bakery
some people aren't that bothered but he
smells bread and his grin response just
goes through the roof but it could also
be that you don't really like exercise
that much and it could also be that you
don't really uh enjoy eating foods that
are a little bit leaner and it could
also be you know there's lots of
different ways to get the Kao equation
to work against you from an obesity uh
perspective and just because I come from
I have a background where I would be T
I'd be like 63 kilos if I'd never been
to the gym that's not the same
disposition that everybody has that
being said there is an awful lot of
agency like ultimately if you don't put
it in your mouth it doesn't go into your
body right so finding this balance
between um empowerment and reminding
people of the sovereignty and agency
that they have over their health and
fitness whilst accepting that the base
that people are working from is not the
same the difficulty some people are
swimming upstream and some people are
swimming Downstream right uh and I think
again from Max I'd be interested to know
if you agree with this that as far as
he's concerned
the current world that people find
themselves in if they want to eat foods
that do not cause them to be obese if
they want to not eat Beyond satiety they
are finding it harder to do now than
ever before because of how ultr
processed foods are hyperpalatable
they're more calorie dense they're
quicker and easier to put into your
mouth and get into your stomach they're
more readily available you're able to
graze throughout the day all of the
things again that get this Kao equation
the balance to just lean more and more
and more and more
toward Surplus
calories it's never been more difficult
to be
underweight right or to be of a healthy
weight exactly and also even with all
those things you just shared we have
this new
category huge list of obesogens so these
are obesity obes obesity causing agents
that are affirmed in particular they are
riddled with obesogens in Ultra
processed foods so it's it's similar to
a carcinogen a cancer-causing agent
which according to the who for example
glyphosate which has been on a lot of
people's conversation list recently
glyphosate according to the W is the
lawn killer the weed killer stuff yeah
yeah Monsanto and I'm from St Louis Home
Base I went to work there after college
and so glyphosate according to the who
is classified as a class 2A
carcinogen that means that it probably
causes cancer in humans that's why
there's so much unrest about it but this
has been known for quite some
time and by the way this is in the East
Mar family cookbook too because what
does this translate to am I really
getting exposure well the environmental
working group took a bunch of the most
common grain products on us store
shelves and and analyze them for
glyphosate content they found 80 to 90%
of conventional grain products were
contaminated with glyphosate a probable
human
carcinogen and again carcinogens
obesogens these are going to be things
that are often found in significant
content in Ultra processed foods yeah so
I don't understand the obesogen thing is
that just a uh component of food which
makes it more likely to be overeaten
what's these are these are synthetic
chemicals that literally alter our
metabolic function and and contribute to
the process of weight gain give us some
EX on their own one of the most ominous
sounding obesogens that we're all
getting exposed to pretty much every day
is bisphenol a all right so this is in
food packaging and so this is a plas
plasticizing chemical so Plastics are
made from fossil fuels and I see
plastics every I mean you can't so much
of this is
made from plastic it's made our lives
you know it's the the material you know
it's like the look the feel of cotton
the fabric of the look the feel of
plastic the death the killer of Our
Lives
sorry Plastics are awesome in their own
right but in regards to their
interaction with our food is a serious
Pro problem I just had a conversation
with a board certified toxicologist who
worked in the flavor and fragrance
industry
and she shared with me that you know
even for example when we go to a coffee
shop you know you get that tog go cup
and it's a paper cup why is that hot
liquid not like melting the cup or like
breaking the cup down it's because the
inside has a certain type of plastic oh
God and the data now she shared a study
with me that you're consuming From Any
Given cup of coffee regular serving size
of coffee at least
25,000 microplastics 25,000 and there's
microplastics and there's
nanoplastics and she shared with me that
these microplastics again bisphenol a is
just one plasticizer chemical there's
bisphenol s there's so many but we can
get tricked because it's Health washing
saying this is BPA free but she said
that this the inter they can interact
with our cells directly and function
sometimes as like xenoestrogen compounds
so activating estrogen Pathways this is
why we see the correlation with breast
cancer we see the correlation with gtia
with breast tissue development with men
and so we've got that aspect but she
said the primary thing that's happening
we're seeing in the data is that is
contributing to inflammation and so I'm
saying all this to say with our food
supply it isn't just the food itself
it's also what the [__] is packaged in
wow so you're saying that even if I
avoid the soy when I go to starbu there
still other estrogens floating around in
the thing that they give it to me in and
even with soy again soy has been
utilized for thousands of years by
humans when you look at the data and I
used to again because as soon as I heard
xenoestrogen with soy I immediately put
it on the do not disturb list you know
and the reality is the way that it
functions in the body is not quite like
we kind of create that superficial term
of a xenoestrogen and like all these bad
things messing up testosterone that
being said traditionally people were not
guzzling soy milk and eating soy dogs
and having a toe furky for you know
Thanksgiving I'm going to guess then
that the storage of food especially if
someone a lot a lot of guys that are
listening to this will be gim Bros
they'll be doing their food prep perhaps
on a Sunday or perhaps each morning they
need to be looking very carefully at
what it is that they're storing this
food in especially hot food taking it
from the pan into their tupperware
container uh blitzed all of mine and
pivoted they they do this so tupp
whereare do glass based uh storage
containers so you can do that but even
that has a plastic lid so I'm trying to
find a solution now if anyone knows one
of a All Glass storage container would
probably need to be a liter and a half I
think lit and a half to two lit seems
about right because you get some spinach
and throw that on top and do all you
want room uh
but yeah dude for a decade I thought
that Health was and you know stepping
over uh dollars to pick up pennies it's
probably better to be eating good food
that you've cooked yourself that you
know and being like oh maybe there's
some bpas in this Tupperware is supposed
to oh well I'll just go and continue to
order on Uber Eats each day or whatever
it might be um but yeah you even if
you're cooking your stuff at home what
are you storing that in once it's done
it's hot it's going direct from the pan
straight into so what's your solution
you prep food your entire new cookbook
is all about this what's your solution
you're on the road you want to make sure
you're eating well how are you storing
your food and taking it with you yeah I
mean a simple thing if you don't want to
throw all your Plastics Away by the way
for your food storage which I haven't we
still have some stuff we're cycling it
out over time phased out you know and
you do want at least let your food cool
down because we do know that the heat
interaction so a recent like this study
was just published and they the the
researchers put food into a quote
microwave safe plastic container and
microwaved it for 3 minutes and they
found that in a three c space of that of
that
container
released literally 50,000 plus
microplastics and we're
talking millions of nanoplastics into
the food and that's just from a three
cimet space of it so just we're not
we're not heating our stuff up in the
microwave in a in a 3 cm thing it's it's
larger a lot so this is real it's a
thing we don't want to be too neurotic
but if you can avoid it avoid it don't
make hot food don't put your hot food in
there or don't heat it up in there if
you can what do I do I love stainless
steel stainless steel containers for
food with the Silicon lid is great um do
you have any brands that you use you
know I did I put some in the bonus
resource guy for the cookbook and
actually I talk about this in the
cookbook like food storage as well glass
is great as well these been used
traditionally uh glass for for a long
time for food storage and you know Stan
eing vertical diet guy uh his solution
for his favorite meal Monster Mash uh is
a thermos so he gets a cylindrical
thermos and like Scoops his food in uh
and you get double benefit from that
that you can do it from hot it'll go
straight in it will stay hot for you
know 10 or 12 hours throughout the day
and it's just stainless steel all the
way upsome that's a potential you can
also just I guess drink your food
potentially although he does say he did
talk to me about how he gets some
strange looks both going through TSA
when they say thermos they presume that
there's liquid in there and when they
look more closely it's beef and rice and
and other stuff and then also that he's
got a special long Fork that he uses to
get to the bottom of this thing so if he
is on a plane and he's just m he's like
260 280b super Jack dude big bald head
uh and I kind of imagine what it's like
to sit next to him you're already like
this up against the window and this
massive guy pulls out a thermos and just
starts eating a daddy long legs Fork
yeah it starts eating meat from it with
this like special flight safe super long
Fork yeah uh so that's a I mean people
have kind of really got obsessive over
the BPA stuff and I'm always cautious
even though it's like it's interesting
and it it's something that could be
hiding in plain sight and it's an easy
change like you use the story that you
have so if you change the storage that
you have it's now no longer a problem
for you right so it's a single time
decision that pays off Downstream
but how big of a problem is this is this
a a penny or is this a dollar when we're
looking at this from a obesogen
perspective I think it's in the middle
tier got you okay 50 Cent yeah shout out
to Curtis Jackson yeah um but because
it's so pervasive it's so pervasive you
know in our food system and nobody
stopped to ask is this a problem for
humans I didn't even think about the
fact that the inner coating of
disposable coffee cups would have this
so I'm going to guess that if someone
that's listening is a big coffee person
and they enjoy their Starbucks or Costa
or whatever it is uh that you would say
get yourself a good quality steel
stainless steel lined thermos type
coffee cup of some kind take that and
give it to them they'll do all of the
fancy stuff that you want but do not be
using the posable cups if you can
ideally yes if you can again we don't
want to be and here's this is a little
interesting fun story I haven't shared
this but um I was with my wife and we
had like a little
station and usually you know I bring my
for sigmatic and I make uh coffee in the
room and they didn't have coffee mugs in
the room at the moment and I just it
kind of you know was a little bit of a
time crunch we had something to do and I
was like they only have these like
reusable paper you know the paper cups
with the plastic lining and I was
telling my wife like babe you know they
only have this whatever she was like I
don't care because she doesn't care but
when she listened to my guest the board
certified toxicologist shout out to Dr
Ivon burkhard my wife just happened to
listen to that episode and she she was
talking to me every five minutes I was
in the other room just trying to do some
Mobility work like relax it was a long
day and she every 5 minutes babe did you
know oh the plastic the paper cups like
you were right and because it it came
from somebody else you know so so dude I
you and Max it doesn't it doesn't
surprise me that you guys are friends he
was telling me that when uh his mom was
still with us that she wouldn't always
listen to the advice that he gave her if
he told her directly but if he went on
Dr Oz and said it she would be accepting
of it as long as it was through a more
like highly
uh credentialed delivery mechanism even
though it's still him right it's still
the sun it's just not the sun on
FaceTime or sat ups at the dinner table
a lot of people deal with this you know
um I I talked with Tony Robbins not too
long ago and he said that there's a
statement it's a you know it's been said
for a long time but he said and it just
like really jumped out of me that you
can't be a prophet in your own land
sometimes right and so the proximity
with people that know you sometimes
especially if they change your diapers
for example it might not land the same
way the medium is the message exactly as
as if Dr o said it and so fortunately I
happened upon that Insight when I was
working with people running an office
working as a nutritionist day in and day
out that you know a lot of times when
people are wanting to again make a
change if it's coming from that person
and they're going back to their
household right so they want this
Behavior they they want this result I'm
giving them the science back Behavior
change to do do it then I'm sending them
to a culture that's fighting against
them yeah yeah yeah yeah if they were to
come in and just just they start
spouting off the stuff it would be a
challenge and so one of the things that
happens so much when people come up to
me a lot of times it be like you know my
wife or my my husband or my my kids or
you know my mother is always talking
about you and we've changed so much
because Sean says is like a thing in the
household right because it's that it's
that external voice yeah of course back
by science and also it's most of the
stuff that we're talking about makes
sense it's how many how many guys do you
think are going to listen to this today
and say to their wife this evening that
they should have sex before they go to
sleep and then finish it up with because
Shan says because Shan say PR the shirts
because Shan says PR the shirts with the
arrow pointing down let's
go
[__] yeah [__] yeah I um I think you
know we've moved it's interesting we
spoke about culture right at the very
beginning and
this again we're trying to play this
game of not moralizing of bringing
people along for the ride of not you
know pointing the finger and accusing
people of stuff and
yet there is a like making Health normal
again seems like such an like an odd
pivot it would it would almost have to
reverse this uh accounting for and and
ACC climatizing
for poor health outcomes whether it be
uh changing the size of plane seats or
whether it be the the all of the
different changes that people are
looking to do with menus with accounting
all of this stuff it's very strange to
think about okay what would a set point
healthy Society look
like Krishna mty said that it is no
manner of Health to be well adjusted to
a profoundly sick Society my man yes yes
that's what we're experiencing right now
it is normal to be unwell we are living
at a time this is the first time in
human history where if you are healthy
you are not normal and this is a
fact but our definition of normal of
course is very complicated y we want to
normalize Health we want to create a
culture that makes it easy to be healthy
and that's what's possible I spent many
years again I've been in this field for
21 years trying to address the larger
culture and I've made a remarkable
impact coming from somebody who I went
to when I went to college I lived in
Ferguson Missouri a glorified food
desert of the highest order and I grew
up I had multiple chronic illnesses
myself chronic asthma hospitalized every
year I had an arthritic condition an
advanced arthritic condition diagnosed
when I was 20 years old my spine was
breaking down I broke my hip at track
practice like that's crazy that
shouldn't happen to a
child to come from that to write the
firstly Wellness related book to become
an international bestseller I think
we've got maybe 25 foreign separate
foreign book deals like it's crazy it's
like in libraries in China you know it's
crazy it's crazy but that's what's
possible I have made a dent in the
bigger l in the bigger culture scape but
that is a tremendous task it heavy it
is life sucking and energy draining to
do that and it's it's very very
difficult it is a like an I get I'm
right now Conjuring up an image of Atlas
all right or Copus maybe right yeah
yes now with that being said let's
address that
but let's first and foremost address I
just had this great conversation with a
man named Greg
Harden and I'm man I'm so grateful to
have met this man
he's he's really the first Mentor in
college for Tom
Brady Michael Phelps Charles Woodson the
list goes on and on he's like a
superpower for them meeting him changed
the course of their lives Tom Brady was
like fourth string when he met
Greg what Greg said to me and he said
when he said it again it hit different
because we've heard this before control
the controllables control the
controllables Tom was so concerned with
trying to change things that he couldn't
control what he could control was the
way that he was training what he could
control was taking advantage of the
opportunities that he was giving no
matter how small they were the starting
quarterback was getting 20 reps back up
10 reps Tom was getting like two he was
like make those two the greatest two
hum Humanity's ever seen he fra reframed
it like that he put some power back into
his hands for him to control the
controllables what what do we do in this
context with a larger culture scape that
is
unwell focus on your microculture
intentionally create a microculture
around you that makes Health easy that
makes movement easy that makes good
sleep
easy right
now again stepping out our door it's
very difficult to control those things
but within under our own roof and by the
way I'm I want to make this
clear we are products of our environment
we can't help it we are influenced by
the things in our environment all the
time but humans are also creators of our
environment we can create an environment
intentionally that that's what makes us
so remarkable we can create an
intentional environment that makes this
stuff
easy with that said the environment
starts with us us the culture starts
with us we are representation of our
culture got to shout out Gandhi in this
one to be the change like people say
that [__] like seriously we want
everything else to change outside of us
the truth is it's an inside job first
and foremost because here's the cool
thing when you take yourself like you're
from across the pond when you come here
though you're representation of your
culture you can't help it it's beaming
Off Of You the suaveness the accent all
the things it's just coming off please
come on all right when we show up
anywhere we bring our culture with us
it's
infectious we have
this we attribute contagious things to
just negative things but Wellness is
contagious as well and we've got data
affirming that too the Framingham heart
study for example and
so let's focus on creating a
microculture in our household what does
that look like I shared for me the core
of that which is community family and
friends because it's the biggest
leverage point it feeds into itself when
you can focus on creating healthy
relationships especially in close
proximity to you which is something
we're never we we not taught about how
to have good relationships which is the
most impactful thing on our lives we go
to school and we learn about
like I
don't times taes or what ever you know
like that's cool that's cool but that's
not going to impact my life more than
how do I learn how to be a good listener
how do I become a person of value so
that people want
me in their relationship right so for me
it's focusing on controlling the
controllables be the type of person of
value who can have great relationships
that's part of listening to this right
now what you've created is helping us to
be better people right so investing in
that you're already winning you're
already starting the process and
building on that
process also in your own microculture
with your with your food know
thyself if you can't have Cheetos in the
crib without having orange fingers
definitely don't bring them in and we
don't have to villainize
Snickers if we want to if we want to
dabble in that I got Snicker bites in
the cookbook high quality ingredients
real food ingredients we've got I
mentioned the Cherry frozen yogurt pops
if you want a sweet Frozen treat right
let's upgrade the ingredients we know
our culture we like that stuff we like
popsicles you know we like burgers we
like chocolate let's just okay that's
cool because the processed food industry
are the ones that really [__] it up
for us all right humans we innately are
driven to eat things that taste good to
us I know the top guys in all the
different diet Frameworks one of my guys
is the Eat to Live don't live to eat guy
I couldn't be any further from my
perspective on that not based on like
that just doesn't sound good but because
of biology we have this really
Immaculate intelligent
flavor receptor system that's our the
human knows and and the in our pallet
the interface there is so cool we can
taste things that are just
mindblowing with that like V in the
[__] wines like I T it's a hint of
like a a Hot Wheels car and like dirt
like they're all of these subtle flavor
notes that we can identify and that
helped us to survive because we can
taste whether or not that food was good
for us and there's this phenomenon
called post-ingestive
feedback have you heard of this before
no postingestive feedback is essentially
whenever we through our Evolution and
today if we were to eat a food our cells
our biology would take notes essentially
on what it just got from that
food and flavor is the language it's
like the label it's a flavor label so
for example the cherries that I talked
about earlier we eat the food okay we
get some bioavailable melatonin we get
these antioxidants we get these
particular amino acids we get this
vitamin C your your biology is taking
notes that flavor is attached to those
nutrients so when I become deficient in
those nutrients I'll develop a craving
for that
flavor that's how we're hardwired
food scientists have [__] that whole
thing up one of the inventions of gas
chromatograph can I isolate flavors
based on the chemistry like this cherry
flavor here's the chemistry to make it
now we can take that flavor and add it
to ice cream we can add it to soda we
can add it to Candy we can add it to all
this [__] that is not cherries and so it
muddies up these metabolic Waters I
learned today about Mountain de flavored
hot
dogs
yo Frankenstein is here
walking around us in the form of a
wiener all right it's real it's real
like this is where we are today where
our our biology doesn't even understand
or Recognize Real Food anymore so we've
got to take back control because the LIE
is that that [__] tastes better than
real food that's not that's not even
close our most memorable meals are often
times the ones that are prepared by
somebody that loves us and they're made
from Real Food they're quote made from
scratch real food
meals we don't often have very like
super memorable moments with a bag of
Cool Ranch Doritos speak for yourself
okay shout out to Jay Leno who was in
the first commercial for that that [__]
was good all right and with that being
said you know this what we're talking
about here is my guy Mark Shater you
know in the Dorito effect and looking at
again being able to take the flavor of a
taco and putting it on a chip but now
you're not getting the potential veggies
the grass-fed meat meat the whatever
else might have been in the real even
the conversation with the guy in the
food truck that made it there you go
we're missing all we just go right
straight to hand in the bag you're
jacking that bag off yeah all right
again speak for yourself all right so
here's the bottom line we want to take
back control of our pilot and to do that
food isn't just food it's information
when you're bringing in more of these
real foods and in ways that are Absol
delicious should be a no-brainer but in
ways that are fun that create incredible
like food memories and experiences like
taking the salmon and having a delicious
salmon burger right now we're getting in
all that vital data from those Foods
it's changing what's happening with our
genes we normalize that in our
environment because instead of whatever
the [__] else we were going to have as
far as a burger was concerned now we've
got this I made a batch of them got them
in the freezer for whenever I want like
we start to create an environment again
that makes it easy to make healthy
choices so know thyself if you can have
some Cheetos at the crib and not go ham
on them when you're stressed that's
that's cool for most people don't bring
that [__] in anymore but treat yourself
treat yourself good make sure if you
know your if you like if you're a
sweetie pie like my wife she's she's a
sweetie she loves
sweets knowing that we we make sure that
we keep a stash of the good stuff for
her if she ever has that inclination
that she wants some you know some
chocolate or whatever we got a higher
quality chocolate bar in there we've got
you know a higher quality uh you know
the Snicker bites we've got this
superfood chocolate bark you know we got
all these different things that she can
have to address that desire so focus on
the
microculture hell yeah Sean Stevenson
ladies and gentlemen Sean I really
appreciate you man where should people
go you got brand new book out you got
loads of other stuff going on where
should they go yeah so the book just
came out I'm so grateful this week and
as of this recording and it's available
nationwide at bookstores and of course
at Amazon Barnes & Noble on online all
that good stuff I actually just saw
today that because the book was number
one cookbook in the US on Amazon oh yeah
they dropped the price so it's 50% off
right now on Amazon for people if they
pop over to Amazon thank you Mr Bezos
yeah shout out and so it's the eats
smarter family cookbook as I mentioned
there's over 250 scientific references
in this cookbook and most importantly
though we identified about 40 of the
most science back foods for improving
metabolic Health Sleep Quality the list
goes on on and on and how to make
delicious foods with them delicious
meals with them so yeah pick up the eart
family cookbook invest in your in your
family and your health great gift to
give as well and people can find me
where they're watching or listening to
this uh my show is called the model
Health show and I'm grateful to say it's
been the number one Health podcast in
the country many many times and we do
master classes there on every subject
matter you can imagine myself and I
bring on the very best people in their
respective Fields as well and it's just
a special place and it's all free you
know just click play and you're going to
get something special damn right Sean I
appreciate you thank you man thank you
for having me thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
with Shan then you will love my
three-hour brand new conversation with
Dr Andrew
huberman go on give it a press